hey Conan O'Brien here welcome to
serious jibber-jabber I'm sitting here
with the author of 11 New York Times
bestsellers most notable among them are
liars poker Moneyball and The Blind Side
his latest flash boys uncovers some of
the unsightly ways that the stock market
actually works very happy to be joined
by Michael Lewis Michael thanks for
doing this thanks for having me read the
book and I'm gonna be completely honest
as you love the book sections and I
mentioned this to you before there are
sections that I didn't understand what I
was reading
I am worried I'm terribly wired I'm
terribly wired for for Finance the world
of financial transactions especially
when we're parsing it down to
milliseconds on computers sometimes
escapes me but it was still a
fascinating ride so parts of it where I
think the most complicated things I had
to ever write and the the reason I had
to explain them is that Wall Street has
made itself so complicated intentionally
so you do not understand it because your
understanding is something that can be
your misunderstanding is something that
can be exploited to me there was like
this technical detail I had to bring
across to the reader just to satisfy
people who had that degree of curiosity
yeah but there was really a pretty
simple story and the simple story was
guy who works on Wall Street it was a
trainer runs the trading desk at the
Royal Bank of Canada discovers around
2008 that he's a he's someone there's
some predator out there who he was and
who knows what he wants to do in the
market before he doesn't and is
exhorting exploiting him and he
discovers that it isn't just him and
this sort of anybody who's an investor
is on the receiving end of this
predatory activity he figures out what
they're doing explains it goes and
explains it to other people who were
prey and then he goes out to try to
destroy the predator so it's a it's one
part like detective story figuring out
what happened in one part kind of
revenge story let's let's get the bad
guys it's got a slight elements of like
The Untouchables let's get a ragtag
group of people together to fight the
bad guys yeah I was thinking of the
Dirty Dozen right yeah or actually what
I thought what I was thinking I think
everyone gets killed in the dirty desk
this one isn't over yet yeah everyone
may get killed in this yeah you're gonna
be careful yeah you know so it was
interesting so this guy name's Brad
Katsuyama he's Canadian one of the
things that is curious about this ragtag
group people is almost none of them
American they're all mostly immigrants
yeah and most Ament some idea about how
this society was supposed to work and it
was supposed to be fair in certain ways
and they they were whatever reason
slower to buy into the idea that just
because you work in the financial sector
you have to sort of behave the way a lot
of people work in the financial sector
behave they they they they saw this
thing that was clearly not good they and
they said about trying to fix it rather
than exploit it I mean and and to me
what interested to me and telling the
story he was almost just that it was
like why do some people if you see a
like like you see a big oil pipe
carrying oil from one side of the
country to the other and someone comes
and whacks a hole in it and it makes a
fortune out of the oil coming out of the
hole and a whole like ecosystem grows up
around this pilfered oil why does
somebody walk into that situation say
let's fix the hole in the pipe to get
out there I'm gonna take a boil and then
so that's what happened effectively a
pie a pipe got busted in the financials
in the stock market an echo system grew
up around it to exploit the busted pipe
it wasn't without anybody making the
slightest effort to fix the pipe in fact
they all the effort in the financial
system was to preserve the size of the
hole maybe increase the size of the hole
and I just want to be to clarify what's
fascinating in this book is wood for
which I did not know is that people were
exploiting the speed at which trades
were made electronically right so should
I say it because you might confuse
people
yes the nicest thing anyone's ever said
to me Oh suddenly I became a grandfather
who's not allowed to drive the car and
you take it Michael I can't anymore I'll
probably confuse cattle too because it
is a little confusing the the there are
13 stock exchanges now in this country
not just one not just in New York Stock
Exchange so you might buy or sell like
AT&T on 13 different places and these
Exchange's now sell to insiders to
high-frequency traders the right to put
their computer right next to the
exchange and get information about
what's happening on this change before
everybody else so they know when prices
move before everybody else so so like
some people have a few millisecond
advantage in finding out what prices are
right those same people go to the
brokers that you give your stock market
order to whether it's etrade or merit
trade one of the online people are
whether it's JP Morgan or Merrill Lynch
or whoever and they buy the right to
trade against your trade your
slow-moving trade yep
so they may know the stocks gone down or
up if it's good they will know if it's
moved at all and you don't and they have
the right to trade against you so it's a
constant opportunity to exploit the
slowness with which you're you're
getting information or another way of
looking at it is it's a constant
opportunity to exploit the informational
value of what you're trying to do and
this would happen this guy the main guy
the hero the book he was a Wall Street
guy I mean he was trading hundreds of
millions of dollars of stock but he
would go to the his trading screens
would say they're 20,000 shares of
Microsoft available at $20 a share and
he'd say okay I want to buy him he hit
his button and one day he hits his
button and all of a sudden and then he
tries to buy and they go away and the
stock goes up and it's like it's because
the traders could see what he wanted to
do and they did in front of him so it's
it's like this built in and what's up
with so I don't know it's not sinister
it's more it sort of like persistent
about the problem is that it's this
built-in skim of pennies on every
transaction so you don't really feel it
I mean you lost a penny who cares you
lost a penny but when you add it up over
the whole market its billions and
billions of year of basically grift and
nobody says anything I mean it's just
obviously wrong it's obviously the only
point of this grid this skim is to
benefit well the guys who are having to
be inside the exchanges and the
financial sector as a whole at the
expense of the broader economy and you
would think that someone would say
really this shouldn't be going on I mean
you would think that and it took they
took these guys I thought so what
interested me what's interesting is
they're they're not there's an Irish
immigrant there's a there's a Canadian
did take people from outside outside
which makes you when you read the book
question do we are we not teaching
ethics in this country anymore are other
countries or are there other systems
where people might be more inclined to
feel ethically than they would if he was
a really great question I think you I
think it's a really good question cuz
you go I think what has happened is the
people who are sitting in the middle of
this system and making money from it
they're the brightest graduates of the
best schools in the country who've
basically taken in the idea that it if
you make a lot of money you're a success
and it's tough that what they're doing
is they illegal I don't think anybody
actually broke any laws they took
advantage of a mistake in the system a
glitch in the system rather than fix the
system that the the the success that the
feelings of success that came with the
making of the money completely
overwhelmed the sense that wow this is
this is actually not good what's going
on and that basically a basic moral
sense is numbed in a lot of people and I
think that this is true when you become
part of systems
I mean you it's just it's the culture of
the of Wall Street and this guy brad
katsuyama who sort of leads this charge
I mean he gets moved from Canada to the
United States and as the more he's
exposed to the American Way of finance
the more insane he becomes I mean the
more upset he becomes he just is he has
almost a physiological reaction to his
blood pressure starts going up he can't
sleep at night and so and so forth he
actually it violated his moral sense
what was going right and it's odd you
know if that makes it all sound very
pious and humorless and all the rest
it's it's not that he is a pious person
not at all it's like a regular guy kind
of a good guy
he just he didn't care enough about the
money to violate his own moral sense to
get it and so I do think it's a question
worth asking like why aren't more people
who were big successes on Wall Street
more concerned with like just making it
work well for everybody as opposed to
just get dollars and this goes to a
bigger theme that you write about which
is access to information that that in we
think of ourselves in America's having
this democratic
system or trying to be fair as fair as
possible we like to think that our
markets are fair we like to think that
it's the land of opportunity that if you
have a talent you can rise the top and
what's becoming increasingly clear and
what you've written about in your books
is that people with access to some
information have an advantage and the
technology now exists where certain
people can have access to certain
information and it gives them a big
advantage over other people it's not a
fair market that's exactly right
it's a it is I think if you read the
story it's hard to conclude anything but
the market is rigged it's rigged in a
way that you know you can investors can
still make money in the market and so on
and so forth but they're their players
in the marketplace who have such a
systemic advantage that they'll go a
thousand days of trading stocks without
ever losing money because it's just they
have right it's it's a totally unfit the
and the advantage comes from basically
where you sit in the world and if you
happen to sit on the inside of the
financial system you have this advantage
and it is that's probably always been
true I'm sure it's always been true that
the people who were inside the financial
system have an advantage over everybody
else and the the game is to get there
but it is it is a little I think it is a
little metaphor for the culture that is
sort of like all dollars in the
marketplace
don't stand the same chance that some
doubt some people's dollars have have
advantages unfair advantages over other
people's dollars well probably the
biggest issue in the country right now
that's a that's a pretty heavy statement
but yeah I will say that one of the
biggest issues is is income inequality
disappearing middle class we have this
layer of incredibly wealthy people a
smaller middle class that shrinking and
then we have a lot of people that have
inadequate incomes and
then the question is why is this
broadening why is this getting bigger
why is this income inequality seem to be
growing and growing and growing it's
obviously a complicated question yes
yeah so let's just accept it's a
complicated question yes do with
globalization rights probably but given
that given that these trends that and
you could feel it right you can feel
like the gaps between rich
everybody else just feel very they feel
like they're growing and you don't need
you don't even need the statistics to
see you see it on the leaf see iLife
some people fly on jets and some people
flying don't fly right and and the but
given that given this is happening it
seems insane to me that we allow the
financial sector which is what you're
supposed to be pure at least there's
it's supposed to you would think in
theory it's supposed to the stock market
it's like it mo supposed to be a
regulated you Mach retires Markham
financial organ in the world supposed to
be a level level playing field it seems
crazy that you structure these markets
to make the rich richer and everybody
else's expense
well that's explaining like my kids
asked me what they're vaguely interested
in whatever book I'm writing not
terribly but sometimes I'll say like
what's the book about and I said well
this is that it's actually a very weird
story I say these guys on Wall Street
who are really rich have figured out how
to take pennies away from everybody else
you don't isn't very rich our rich and
it adds up to billions of dollars and
say rich people steal money from other
people I said well it's stealing is not
exactly what's going on but it's pretty
closely that's awful the it is awful and
some guy saw it was awful and he came
and he decided to take it back it's
right and they said it's Robin Hood and
that is basically the story it's the
story of Robin Hood but it does seem
crazy that as a matter of public policy
we do not try to cut off these gambits
by the well-to-do insiders to to take
advantage of people who are not right
because there are all these other forces
at work there are already widening gaps
I mean why while I have a market that's
in contributing to this you know it's
you can't talk about this and nothing
about the mortgage-backed securities
fiasco we had a couple of years ago
which is we're still feeling the effects
of that right and how it's clear to me
that many people in this country knew
that this wasn't sustainable knew that
this was toxic but just kept the ball
rolling going back to the question of
ethics that there were a lot of people
working in the system who understood
this is going to blow at some point we
keep that's true and and then there was
a national
cry afterwards there's been a crime
obviously committed terrible errors have
been made people have to pay for it and
there's a sense that nothing happened
there was no you know there was no trial
there was no no-one it felt like no one
paid the price no one went to jail
nobody I think the political I think I
think what basically what happened was
all right so we have this
I mean basically maybe the worst the
most spectacular financial crisis in in
our history generated really by by
machination on Wall Street to disguise
the risk of lending money to people who
never pay it back yeah and that happens
and what naturally usually follows a
financial crisis is a depression right
and the Federal Reserve has been really
good at numbing the pain and in numbing
the economic pain they sort of reduced
the political will to make changes I
think that's what happened so that the
anger went out of it as it became clear
that this was going to be a protracted
recession as opposed to depression
whatever but and the strategy of the
government was and it may not have been
a bad strategy it was sort of like well
in order to like make sure we don't have
a depression we've got to prop up these
existing banks that all would fail if we
didn't prop them up and resuscitate them
but in resuscitating them they also
resuscitated their political power so
they had their money had a lot of has a
lot of influence on what how they're
regulated and it's all outrageous and
it's all unfair and you have this this
giants like sector in the economy the
financial sector or at least the big
banks the big banks that are essentially
kind of like removed from the rest of
the society and most people are exposed
to market forces like if you fail you
fail if you are a trader on Wall Street
it's not quite as simple as that that
you get to keep your winnings
someone else gets stuck with your losses
kind of thing it's a bit of that going
on and it is I mean it I think that to
some extent the response to this book
has been like unslaked anger about about
the outcomes of the
after the financial crisis it just like
violated the basic rules of the system
like you can't have the richest people
in the society living by one set of
rules where they don't have to fit they
never fail no matter how badly they do
their job they don't fail and then
everybody else living by like red and to
think law capitalism so I think that
that it there is an unsettled quality to
the relationship between Wall Street the
financial sector and everybody else and
what's interesting to me about this
particular episode this story that I've
written one of the things is that these
guys who raise their hand and say
there's a broken pipe we need to fix
this system they're like trying to
repair the relationship they're they
trying to do is introduce trust back on
Wall Street
well they build they they come up with a
software program they come up with a
exchange - they build their own Stock
Exchange right on which the predator
can't function and the way they do it is
they pick essentially coil like 60
kilometers or 630 miles or whatever is
38 miles of fiber between themselves and
the Predators machines so the Predators
they're essentially ban it effectively
put far far away from the activity so
they can they may know things that
everybody else doesn't know in the
marketplace but they can't react to it
on the exchange
so they level that they real 'evil the
playing field the poi of reliving the
play for it's not just like to make the
stock market fair that's I you know
that's the that's the narrow goal but
the broader goal is like to create an
environment where people actually
deserve to be trusted like the people
who were sitting in the middle of the
system are actually trustworthy and when
you do that it's really seditious
I mean investors the way I got onto this
story is big investors told me this guy
from Wall Street
Brad katsuyama just walked into my
office and told me the truth about how
the stock market work and my jaws on the
floor but more the point this the my
Johnson before partly because I can't
believe how it works but my jaws on the
floor guys I can't believe some guy from
Wall Street actually told me the truth
you know and there is no trust in the
system it's a it's like it's bankrupt
that way so someone has to come along
and restore the trust because you can't
just really function very well without
the trust and that's his I think that's
his role in the world and it's been a
success that is exchanges exchange
they're making their already profitable
but it's hard to know how they could be
there's still a bug they could be
squashed they they're less than 1% of
the stock market right now you can
imagine lots of different outcomes it's
not clear they they you know and clearly
there's a lot of people that aren't
rooting for Brad and his exchange all
the entire existing financial system is
root is not rooting for Brad in his
exchange just about there are a few
exceptions it's a little more
complicated than that but basically all
the obviously the existing exchanges and
most of the brokers don't want him to
succeed because he sucks money out of
this yeah right so I mean that effect of
him if he were if they end up over
running the stock market and they become
the stock market basically like people
on Wall Street make 10 billion dollars
less a year or something like that right
so that's not that doesn't you know it's
that's not that's set up for he's set up
for lots of conflict with with people on
Wall Street he said people tell him
they're gonna come beat him up and you
know kneecap him and watch out they're
friends with the Mafia and he's never
getting there many they've been
threatened really oh yeah yeah they were
still kneecapping people that actually
don't meet everything let me no one's
done it you know actually on Wall
Street's funny there are a lot of almost
fights right everybody's there's a lot
of like I almost hit him if he said one
more thing out of hit him right there's
a lot of almost well there's a tamato
it's a very macho culture but there's a
very just thumping culture but then no
one actually that everyone has a lawyer
let's see that's exactly it was afraid
of getting sued so they think yeah I'd
have thrown that punch except that it
would have cost me a million bucks
but there's only so he's in a lot of
almost fights people almost would have
hit him nothing's actually happened so
looking at this the broader issue here
if you look at historically just at the
United States you see that we've been
through this many times we'd actually
been through periods there's the you
know is the Gilded Age where and then
there's reform and then there's a
depression and then there's reform you
know in the 20s we've been through these
periods there was economic
you know turmoil in the late 80s and
then there was a sense that there's
reform and it seems like we never really
learned because my theory is that human
beings we are always we are
evolved to try and game the system true
we it's what we're meant to do we do it
the way we breathe we will game the
system and it's like rain on the roof
will eventually get in right and people
will game the system especially Russians
yeah exactly it's amazing the role of
Russians and all this like the right now
why specifically Russians the Russians
have some Russian immigrants explained
it to me they say that we grew up in a
system where you can only survive if you
gain the system it was not enough bread
you had to figure out how to get the
bread was available but you had to gain
the system to get the bread so when they
get to America it seems like the land of
unlimited gaming opportunities Costco
this I didn't know this but Costco they
apparently Russians discovered that
Costco has an incredibly generous
returns policy you can buy something use
it for a year and 364th they bring it
back and so there's this like it's just
like accepted behavior in the New Jersey
Russian community that you go and do
this you game the Costco returns policy
that's a say but they have if you talk
to a Russian about what you can you can
get away with in America it's
breathtaking
and the Russian the other side of is
that Russian has generated a lot of very
gifted computer programmers and that's
who is gaming the stock market so the
combination of the predisposition to
gaming systems and the experience with
it and the coding ability has led them
to be very prominent in high-frequency
trading business it's almost like yeah
they're there again if you're looking at
evolution they lived in a system where
they had to evolve this way and now
they've come to a fresh environment
right where there's just a lot of fat
veal walking over that's right yes we
have bad eyesight and they have you know
they're quick and they have machetes and
night-vision goggles night-vision
goggles yeah there's and so so at the
end of the day isn't it you know it's in
our DNA to try and gain the systems so
what we need is feels to me like we need
a strong ethical counterbalance it
almost has to be I don't even know if
they teach ethics in schools anymore but
that's the thing I keep coming back to
is there needs to be a counterbalance
there needs to be something that
Institute's reform more often do you
know what I mean that
that's what needs to be part of the
system if anything is that we're always
going to be gaming it there's always
going to be some scam going on in Wall
Street so we need to encourage people to
do what Brad is doing so I think my own
viewing this it without any like
evidence but it's just it just like
might meet when I spout on this subject
I think that we're in a particularly
toxic climate in the relationship
between our elites and everybody else
because in the past when when it
appeared that so much of one's position
in the society was inherited and when it
was less of a meritocratic scramble when
you went to Harvard because your dad
went to Harvard as opposed you went to
Harvard because you got an 800 on your
SATs there was the idea of noblesse
oblige
you know there's a sense that there was
a niggling sense that you you were
basically handed some of this you didn't
actually earn it
so you owe something back right and the
vice of the meritocracy is that you
think I do this myself you know I don't
know anybody anything I'm on top because
I got I belong on top I'm the winner
and so I think that to the extent there
might be ethical evolution in our
culture is getting back it's finding a
way to reintroduce the idea of noblesse
oblige to people who don't understand
why they should feel it and because what
we I mean the problems the problem that
Brad costume is addressing is that is
that promise like people on top seeing
an opportunity to exploit and make lots
and lots of money for themselves and it
doesn't occur to them that that might be
a bad thing to do it just this think oh
that's how I you know that I got here by
by gaming the system I got here by being
smarter than everybody else I'm just
this is just more just rewards for me
and a kind of not a terribly organic
connection to the rest of the society so
how do you teach I mean you say teach
ethics in school and it may be I mean
business schools all pretend to teach it
that nobody wants to say we're not
ethical
they're always embarrassed when some of
their graduates go to jail for various
financial manipulation right but the
real problem is that when guy when
people get rich
doing stuff that's socially destructive
like the subprime mortgage thing right a
lot of people I mean a lot of people
Wall Street got really rich doing really
bad things with money that really stupid
things that contributed the financial
crisis and nobody asked them for their
money back and nobody actually thinks
that ill of them they think oh this is a
rich successful person they never
actually they did they were never on the
receiving end in a serious way of any
kind of disapproval that the there the
mere fact they had lots of money
overwhelmed whatever it was they did to
get the money so I don't know exactly
how you change those attitudes I think I
mean you preach basically I know that
once I mean I tried to sneak I did
commencement speech at Princeton two
years ago and I tried to sneak an idea
and do and the idea is it's sort of like
updating noblesse oblige the idea is all
right there's a huge amount you're a
smart person you understand
probabilities and statistics and there's
a huge amount of chance in life chances
who your parents are you know luck so
accept the idea that if you're lucky you
owe a debt to the unlucky and that that
maybe that's the way to get there but I
don't I completely agree and it is
journalistic heresy to say this because
you're not supposed to think that
they're good people and bad people you
think everybody's just kind of the same
and your objective about them but I
completely agree that the Wall Street
problem now is partly a moral problem
it's partly that the people on top of
the place do not feel a responsibility
and they feel more of a responsibility
to making the money and there's certain
legitimate pressures they run a company
and they're responding the shareholders
and so on but they won't make the up
moral argument and it I think it's a
it's a big issue yeah you could argue
that if you know if you get the time
machine and send people back to a year
before the subprime mortgage implosion
and told people on Wall Street and they
preached this is a problem I'm not going
to sell these they would have been fired
because they would have been yeah it
would've been very hard to do the right
thing yeah because they wouldn't be
around to stop the problem they'd just
be fired you know if you don't sell the
heroin we'll get someone else right
there
oh the company and you say we're not
gonna do this business because they're
responsible and your company's making
all this less money than everybody ever
the company you've no longer the CEO so
the pressures it's it isn't just it is
the people are bad so the system
encourages them to behave not so well
yeah I think the big problem is like I
mean there's an old question about
whether a company should be a public
company they're worse pressures on these
companies these banks the betting side
of the wall street used to not be public
corporations it with private
partnerships it was a bunch of guys who
owned if they lost the money it was
their money it wasn't some shareholders
money if they didn't want to make that
much if they won't didn't want to take
risk they're willing to kind of coast
for a while they did it for a while I
mean they didn't they didn't they
weren't forced always to grope for ever
greater returns and that's a that
pressure is pernicious especially in the
financial sector yeah it there's almost
an unwillingness to accept that their
cycles there's there's certain there's
growth then there's a fallow period then
there's growth again that every system
has a cycle and I think we talked
ourselves especially late twentieth
century America into this idea that no
cycles can exist there must be you know
the success and 15 percent growth every
year or you or you're out and the
problem is that when that pressure
becomes so great you have to guarantee
it and if you have to guarantee it it
means you probably have to start fudging
the numbers you have to start gaming the
system you have to do whatever you can
to do to show that we have the same
growth this year that we had last year
if not a little more because if you have
a little less you might lose your job ya
know this pressure this is true this is
and these are this is I didn't you trace
the problems in modern Wall Street back
to the moment when all these investment
banks became corporations and subjected
themselves to that pressure but yeah
anyway well what you don't think we're
gonna say here to be talking about this
for this long I did actually this that's
the best that's the point you know one
of the themes in your work too is
valuing and Mis valuing if that's even a
word people you know people who other
people don't see the value and it's
obviously a big theme in Moneyball but
blind
side to these exactly like this where
does the this poor black kid on the
streets of Memphis who's illiterate
homeless eating out of garbage cans you
know kind of the least valued member of
our society or among them is transformed
into the most highly valued
seventeen-year-old and the country kind
of thing what are the forces that change
that what would actually change - cause
- cause that change in him or my money
ball is exactly about baseball players
being so Miss value that you could build
this juggernaut of a baseball team out
of discarded parts from other people's
teams and it does this subject is
interested in me since I was missed hi
you I mean and I felt like when I went
to work on Wall Street for a couple
years right after I got out of graduate
school and I was being paid all this
money to do stuff that I knew was there
was no way it was good for the world it
might have been bad it was like at best
this is neutral and I just felt I just
felt totally bogus it felt bizarre and I
I saw how absurd the market was and just
educated felt how observe the
marketplace was I looked all around you
people pay and I paid money not to do
nothing of particular value yeah
so it has interested me as a writer like
how how people get valued because I
think the market does a pretty poor job
of it and the Wall Street doesn't even
grapple with us it's like well it's just
sort of assumed that the market outcomes
on Wall Street makes sense that like it
makes sense you have to pay a Goldman
Sachs trader ten million dollars a year
or else he'll leave and god forbid that
happens right nobody's tested the
proposition of the star systems like
what if we just said we're gonna create
a bank where nobody gets paid very much
maybe it'd be a good bank no maybe it
will actually be a really well
performing bank do we actually need
these highly paid people are they
actually worth what they're paid I mean
there are obviously absurd outcomes in
our economy it is absurd that people got
rich creating financial disaster in
run-up to the subprime mortgage crisis
and at the same time you know teachers
don't get paid anything are very little
I mean it's it's obviously there are
obvious absurdities and yes this
stories I've told often come back to
that the money ball in the blindside in
particular yeah any in Moneyball it was
it's it really does seem to come down to
it's always one person who comes along
it's the same thing in flash boys one
person comes along and sees things
slightly differently they see something
that nobody else sees or they see it in
a different way right and then because
they see in a different way and they and
they start acting on it at first they
meet incredible resistance agility
hostility yeah
because basically a threatening the
livelihoods of everybody in the industry
yeah yeah and the the curious thing is
how slow seemingly really competitive
environments are to react to someone who
got who has a good new idea you think
kind of like in theory if someone coming
along and builds a better widget then
the whole world goes and uses the better
widget and you and everybody all the
other widgets put out a business but
take money ball I mean when I rolled
into Billy Beane's office and it was
2002 he'd been doing this he'd been
winning all sorts of baseball games with
no money for five or six years and
nobody in baseball cared to know what he
was doing I mean nobody they just there
was no curiosity about it at all like
how could how can he pay no but these
people nothing and have all these
players that we don't think are very
good
how can they be winning baseball games
even the players like the players were
they would use them in all kinds of
peculiar ways the first baseman who
never played first base before you say
even he didn't like want to know why he
was playing at first base or is that
what is that is that it just a fear are
people threatened by it what is it that
make someone actively not want to know
what did it mean you'd think it would be
the most important thing if you're a
baseball player you would think you
would think yeah you would think so I
think with guys especially there's a
there's a crazy fear of seeming ignorant
of seeming not to know something that
everybody knows in flash boys you see
this rodent run and Ryan the Irishman
who great character why he's like he
spends 15 years trying to get a job on
Wall Street because he thinks these guys
must know something he gets a job on
Wall Street after six months he says
this whole world floats on [ __ ]
nobody knows anything
and he says he says when he goes around
he's explaining to people you know how
the stock market works and they clearly
don't understand how the stock market
works but they pretend he says you know
that none of the he was shocked that
very very important money managers
wanted to seem like they knew something
they didn't know because they were
afraid to seem not to not know it to
admit ignorance so I think this fear of
admission of ignorance is it's it's
widespread and I think that's part of
the problem
parla problem is I mean people who were
successful and ensconced in careers and
in industries they don't want the
industry to change its pain when it
changes them you've experienced this
right yeah I mean your industry I mean
you see this disruption after about the
age of 24 is not welcome it's funny
there's a time it's some of its
biological I had a friend once that
worked at he worked in Russia and he
worked in Russia just after for the few
years after the the Berlin Wall came
down and I said how's it going and he
said everyone cuz he and he part of his
job is to work with businesses to help
train them in you know capitalist
techniques and business techniques and I
said how's it going and he said
everybody under 33 is doing great right
and he said everyone from like 33 to 40
it's tough right and he said everyone
over 40 we just have to wait for them to
die right like they grew up in the
system where the Soviet Party gave you
your cardboard belt rush shoes and you
you've got your check no matter what
happened and they we just the system has
to and of course obviously there are
exceptions to that but there's something
about us that really doesn't want any
trouble after the age so this is 40 and
this is true in the most fiercely
intellectual disciplines so there's a
great book called the structure of
scientific revolutions that talks about
how how physics of all has evolved and
that a new idea will come into physics
and all the old physicists will bat it
down even though if some young guy has
an idea and and there's a lot in that
book that it's science proceeds a
funeral at a time yeah yeah I mean I
think and I think baseball proceeds a
funeral at a time and Wall Street does
too
I think that's absolutely true that
there's a fierce resistance to people
who were established I mean they're
there if someone comes along into
baseball and says all these all these
players are valuable and you don't know
it everybody who's in baseball and may
and been making baseball decisions is by
implication as by implication made a lot
of bad decisions that they have they're
put in a position of having to defend
all these things they did that made no
sense and that's what they do I mean
that brought it's hard to admit that you
didn't know what you were doing when you
put together your baseball team this way
even for the New York Mets you know that
it was it was so I think it's just when
some disruptive entrepreneurs like
inherently insulting
he's inherently saying that there's
something here that's that's wrong and I
can fix it this way and Brad Kelsey
almost done it here and Billy Beane did
it Moneyball
I think in my business what's happening
is it's it's the internet the internet
is you know this show was something I
couldn't have done five ten years ago
but the bigger implication is we used to
think that and I benefited from the
system a bunch of years ago when the
idea was there a couple of people that
know how to be funny on television at
night right and you know for a long time
there was one guy we got Johnny Carson
and ever occasionally would allow
another one to be around for a bit but
the idea was that he's the only person
well now I'm not competing against other
people the other there's 15 now
talk-show host right I'm not competing
against them I'm competing against
anyone who's got a funny idea in the
world right and can get it posted right
which means that's that's a revolution
that's a huge revolution you feel you're
doing I think it's a step it's a
struggle right you know it's a daily
it's a struggle I will come up with
something that I'm really proud of and
then the next day I'll see that a 13
year old girl you know in Groveland
right made something that made me laugh
harder right and if you're honest with
yourself you you know I want I don't
want to say you welcome it because
there's always a part of you that's
nostalgic for I made it in
how that slows the door let's shut the
door right I mean that be I think it's a
very basic human idea but but but then I
think you're you have to grow up you
have to realize that things are changing
and a lot of staying young is accepting
that you got to accept that it's
changing you have to accept that it's
that it's changing rapidly and you have
to try and figure out what's going on
you know it's happening but it doesn't
anyone who tells you what feels good is
probably lying or insane you know there
it doesn't it's an uncomfortable process
you know it's funny I once talked to a
sociologist who said that this is back
when I was working on the new thing who
was saying explaining me that she
thought the pace of technical change in
America had been accelerating she felt
and that the internet was an example of
this and that the effect on family
relations of a big technology shock like
the internet was similar to the effect
of immigration that that a middle-aged
parent dealing with a child with
technology doing with his doing in
America is a lot like a parent who moves
with his you're their children parents
move their children from Mexico to the
United States and don't speak the
language and the kid quickly picks up
everything yeah I was running circles
around the parents right within about
six months all right that they so it's
like the language the language changes
the kid figures it out first and the
parents are stuck and that's that so the
what happens the parents try to shut
down the technology
yeah that's then they are keep it out or
keep it out of the house keeping all the
kids hands there it's not just the
language and the technology the values
are different too so you know their
values from their old country and versus
the new country so there's a lot of I
think that is true I mean I've you know
the the generation gap between me and
the interns that work on the show is
incredible it's been widened so much by
technology but what's how they
experience TV and how they experienced
entertainment it has nothing to do with
the way that is it's peculiar - it's
funny because you had your own
generation gap and it was you listened
to entirely different music than your
parents would have listened to right
this sexual at least overt sexual mores
would have been completely different but
added towards did - towards different
races completely
I mean in some ways on the surface
anyway you look a lot more similar to
your children then your then your your
parents did to you yes yeah but in fact
it's a little it's it's it's very
unsettling because it's the surface
appearance that beneath it there's this
shift going on I agree that is I look at
my kids and I do not understand their
minds that I do not understand because
of technology like you know what my
daughters are doing on Instagram I just
I can it's don't go look but it's it's
it's just weird yeah I have I have an
eight-year-old who understands the whole
language that I understand we don't let
him he's not allowed to go on the
internet but he's allowed to play the
game minecraft because it's creative and
it's but he wants to write code he he he
helps me with the computer he's eight
right and he'll be like no no no no no
and he'll know and he'll just he'll take
over right so there's that and we're in
a society that increasingly values what
he knows much more than they value what
I know so you see the power shift
already happening you know it's this you
know one of my biggest questions and
fears after reading not just flash boys
but a lot of your books but let's just
stick with flash boys is does anybody
understand the whole system I get scared
sometimes and especially after the
subprime mortgage it felt like no one
could explain it it took such a long
time the Treasury didn't understand that
the Fed didn't understand nobody
understood what had happened nobody knew
where the debt was nobody knew how to
clean this mess up it felt very much to
me I got that we all want to feel that
the grown-ups are in charge and what's
happening in flash boys and what's
happening you know throughout the system
is this scary feeling that there are
these giant servers all throughout the
country that are processing all this
information in fractions of a
millisecond and that nobody really
understands how it all works it's true
yeah I think it's completely true
Brad Cascione understands a lot of it
that's what's so one of the things is
seditious about him is he's trying to
piece together a picture of it he's
presented a picture
is comprehensible to ordinary people
about how the market works and it's not
a very pleasant picture but I've seen in
the reaction to the book the scrambling
of the head of the SEC to pretend like
she knows what's going on I mean maybe
she's learned what's going on but she
didn't know what was going on the
Justice Department and the FBI and the
New York Attorney General all announcing
investigations and you get the feeling
that essentially there were no grownups
right basically it's not it's not that
the grown-ups didn't know so that no one
is actually nobody's actually accepted
the responsibility of understanding the
system that's the most unsettling thing
and that's a theme that runs through
your books I found that unsettling about
Moneyball the people that had devoted
their lives to baseball didn't
fundamentally understand some of the
most basic tenants of what made of
baseball team win well that they weren't
and they weren't willing to obsess they
weren't willing to accept new knowledge
and new information after a certain
point yeah that what had happened was
people knew what they knew about
baseball in 1975 and all of a sudden got
a good-looking swing yeah awaken face
he's got a billion face I like the way
he carries himself there was a lot of
that or his batting average is high but
when that's actually a secondary kind of
trait in a good baseball player right
and all of a sudden people start
beavering away outside of baseball and
creating new baseball knowledge about
what actually makes a good baseball
player and they don't want to hear it
all of a sudden the stock market goes
from being a place where they're a bunch
of guys on a trading floor shouting each
other to nothing but computer servers
and the code is written by people by
people who understand how to write code
but the people who are tasked with like
being the grown-ups in the market they
don't understand what that it didn't
understand what's inside the black boxes
or how they work her or or whether
someone's being disadvantaged in
relation to someone else that they are
it's very complicated I mean you read it
you see I read it so you can understand
why people have been slow to kind of
catch up the understanding has been slow
of the grown ups has been slow to catch
up with a reality but that's what's
happened this reality has shifted very
fast and the grown-ups are only kind of
just starting to figure out what's going
on and you do
I have a fear the paranoid fear after
reading this book that something could
go wrong there was that glitch in the
market I camera flash crash a flash
crash in 2010 where I can remember how
long was it a few seconds like 24
minutes there 24 minutes the the system
didn't work and it scared the [ __ ] out
of everybody but everyone just pretended
everyone held their breath and then it
went back to working and no one wanted
to know no it's great great about that
episode is that you're right no one
wanted no one everyone when I wanted to
just be normal
go back to normal and it went back to
normal to normal and the SEC like a year
later produced a report explaining it it
does not explain it right it's really
it's not true it's not true it's really
obviously not true so but nobody cares
right it's so whoo so there's some right
look the financial system is a
particular problem but in this case I
think the problem is that anybody who
might get themselves in a position to be
a regulator a grown-up who understands
the system who can prevent it from doing
bad things is paid so much more money to
occupy some narrow role inside the
system that there's no way they're ever
going to actually execute they're not
going to they're not going to police or
regulate or explain or moderate the
system the the the SEC for example is
just a revolving door you don't want to
be rude about the people go there
because there are a lot of well-meaning
people who go to work for the SEC who
really think they're going to do God's
work and but the pressures on those
people are to basically turn a blind eye
to anything really bad that's going on
if it's going on in like big prestigious
institutions because they may they will
work they may go to work not just may I
mean when brad katsuyama goes to explain
that there's basically a predator
sitting there monitoring or ready to
exploit every stock market order in the
United States to the SEC
he gets a lot of gobbledygook in
response there is no clear outrage
within the SEC that this is going on he
goes back to his bank on Wall Street the
Royal Bank of Canada and they do a study
and the study asked the question how
many people from the SEC have gone to
work in high-frequency trading firms or
in with lobbyists who worked for
high-frequency trading firms over the
last couple of years and they stopped it
like two I got to 250 people yeah I mean
it's just and you can't you can't really
blame them I mean if you work for the
SEC and they pay you X and you know that
if you just don't know stir up too much
trouble you get paid 10 X 2 years from
now by some bank I mean what are you
gonna do it so the industry has captured
the regulator because the industry is so
well paid but you do want to accept
Wixon is a bigger problem that if
there's no grown-up in other sectors
like on Washington in the political
system is anybody actually understand
how it all works and actually sitting
there thinking about how we make this
better I don't know are you people
policies and just chasing their own
narrow ambition but Wall Street does
feel like it could really use like a JP
Morgan like character someone who yeah
he's a son of a [ __ ] and you know he'd
probably make he makes too much money
for himself but who feels a
responsibility for the system as a whole
from inside the system and it doesn't
feel like any business and that
character exists and has a sense of
history have a sense of I want to stand
for something yeah there's one day I'm
gonna be dead and they gonna talk about
me right and and that's the that's what
you feel is lacking is throughout our
country's history they've been and not
to sound highfalutin but people that
have had a sense of we've had a lot of
our greatest politicians came from
wealthy families Theodore Roosevelt
didn't didn't need this right now
Franklin Roosevelt certainly didn't need
it jonatha d they get it they get
involved their families have a sense
that we owe something back to the system
right and there's oh there's a kind of a
feeling now that you'd like it if it's
having a sense of history if there were
people in Wall Street who thought wait a
minute it would be yeah I'm gonna have a
great place in Long Island
their way right that's the question that
you asked a lot is what is it about
people that when they have two billion
dollars they really are desperate to get
three billion you know when it can't
possibly make a difference in your life
and fortunately we're starting to see
some very wealthy people now say we're
giving away the bulk of our fortune to
these causes because this whole idea of
building up billions of dollars that
will in creating dynastic wealth is is
absurd you know it's that's good it's
interesting how much just just judge
from behavior how much easier it is to
give away your fortune upon your death
yeah than it is to cause real turmoil
and trouble in your industry for the
sake of making of improving it yeah
people don't want to pick fights with it
people don't break with Wall Street
inside wall street there's a hue it's a
it's odd because it's not clubbing
I mean there's no longer actually a club
anymore it's not doesn't feel like that
but it does it feel it does feel like
people are intensely political they want
to preserve they don't want to burn any
of their bridges they they want to
preserve their place in that system so
reforming making improving shrinking the
system is going to cause all kinds of
conflict between you in the system yeah
have you have you gotten flack for
shining a spotlight on oh I mean people
want on this issue understandably when
you write a book that purports to show
how the stock market is rigged to the
people who participate in the reading
are not pleased and so their people have
been yeah people have been playing rude
about me but it doesn't much I don't
think it has much effect I mean I got
shouted on I get shouted at on TV that's
happened a few times right people have
written nasty things about the book but
I don't think I think I'm enough of a
like I have a life apart from all this
and I can write about other things and I
don't think people feel like they can
really get to me or that the focus of
the hostility that seems to
the most pernicious is is the anger and
hatred directed towards the Brad
Katsuyama and the people who created
this exchange yeah and I think there was
you know I didn't actually think anybody
was ever gonna you know like try to off
him or anything but I did worry a bit
about the I knew how disruptive what
they were doing was gonna be before I
wrote the book I did worry a bit about
them
that and they are in the receiving end
of lots of hostility lots of anger and
people will try to put them out of
business
I mean that's that's be that that's so
they're gonna bear the brunt of it
I saw I did this with Billy Beane in
Moneyball to I sort of like walk into
the room picked a fight on their behalf
and left the room ya know come in you
look at everything you write the book
and then and then and I say you know you
two got a fight and then it out my role
is essentially then eventually cowardly
but it makes a good book a good book and
it makes a great move nobody left Billy
Beane and Moneyball in a fight with a
ball a major league baseball for years I
mean until the basically till about the
movie came out right but there's a rule
once you're played by Brad Pitt you're
found innocent yeah then he was off the
hook we have a question on the Internet
you ready for this this is how it's all
changing Chuck from Facebook if that's
even his real name
asks what do you do to get pumped up
before a writing session I listen to
that I listen to let it go over and over
and over I tell you what I didn't left
that was true yeah it was true in this
case yeah what happens what I do it's
funny he asked that question I
I feel like I have to just shut
everything out so I look at I stare at a
wall all the like the screens and blinds
are down on the windows turn off the
phones but I found it's a habit it's
probably a bad habit I've gotten into
but it goes back maybe 15 years now I
have to have I have a music I listen to
put on it put on headphones and I listen
to the same CD I my wife will burn a CD
for me I'll give her a list of songs I
say put these on and I'll just listen to
it over and over so don't hear it
anymore and I've been playing I've been
writing that
that that those same 20 songs for two
years it's about time to stop and move
on to the new 20 songs but it was let it
go was actually hilarious yes so I I
have actually I have put it on repeat
song and listen to it 30 times in a row
why right now helps you it's a real or
I'm realize I would say I'm just saying
this I'm totally chapter in the book
that's just the lyrics to those songs to
the song you realize this it's affecting
your writing so so I'm aware it's weird
but it totally I don't hear it it and it
totally like just it I think I start to
have a black of Pavlovian response yeah
if I go to frozen I'm sure I'll just
want to pull out my pad and start right
unique qualities in the marketing
efficiencies and rice betrayed right but
but I do find that listening to music
often stupid music that that I can just
tune out just like shuts out the rest of
the world
it creates the impact what does is it
creates conditions in which I know I
won't be distracted I won't hear someone
banging on the door I won't hear the
mailman I won't hear a phone ring
whatever it is so it just it like
creates it's white noise do you believe
in the there's the old saying or a
belief that writers get up in the
morning and they only have they've got
two hours they've got two and a half
hours in them and then that's it yeah I
have what I respond to with deadlines so
I panic I have to create the panicky
environment in which I must produce yeah
and then I've done it I've got I've done
it so off and then I actually create
some cushion so that after the panic is
I have time to reflect upon what I've
done and go back through it and fix it
and all the rest but I find that if I
have a deadline I can write any time
yeah it is true that the best time is I
find a write write in the morning and
late at night but we have a little kids
you can't write late at night so it's by
then your drink read if there is the
dread things done yes that's right I've
said that time and time again which is
always unhappiness in creating it yeah
but it's a you see you once you
recognize what the feeling is you you
you can minimize the damage it causes
but yeah totally you have to feel you
have to feel like
angry that you have to do do it yeah a
little irritated that you I need to do
good work I need I need dread and
resentment and and in probably equal
amounts and then something good
sometimes happens comes from it and I've
had people say to me
can't you just let's have the fun part
what about the dread and resentment part
let's lose that and I'll say it just you
got to wind the rubber band yes
tightly to make the propeller go is just
the only way it works like totally agree
totally agree we could I could keep you
here for 4-6 hours but I won't if
there's so much fascinating stuff to
talk about love the book flash boys and
then I think so many people have bought
it but if you haven't bought it go buy
it who does the book on tape this is
their book on tape yeah whose narrating
it we can't say oh you can't say so it's
not gonna be me no yeah parts of it you
don't understand yeah yeah yeah it would
be hard would be argued here me
stumbling yeah you'd hear some soft
weeping at no get this book Michael
Lewis I think this was really cool thank
you for doing this thank you
that was another jibber-jabber hope you
enjoyed it and we'll see you soon
team koco.com slash backslash I don't
know I'm the wrong age dot org we'll see
you soon